Dang that was awesome. Hey, what's up guys welcome back to the workshop in honor of the holidays
I thought it'd be fun for this video to jump back into some pyrotechnics
Now if you saw yesterday's video you'll remember that we tried taking fireworks and dipping them into liquid, nitrogen
And we had some very interesting results this one here was one of the casualties
It is a six shot aerial firework that shoots flaming balls
No joke now only one of these things actually went off
Which means the other five are still packed loaded and ready to go so for this video?
I thought it'd be fun to repurpose these into some other kind of improvised
Pyrotechnic to celebrate freedom the inspiration for today's project comes out of the comments from Andrea flowers who says for the fourth of July you
Should try and make homemade fireworks, so we're kind of doing that today, Andrea?
And we're doing it for you now for this experiment. There are some inherent dangers that we should probably discuss first namely
We're dealing with pyrotechnics that means we want to have some kind of fire suppression system nearby in this case
I've got a 20 pound
Co2 tank if anything happens at all this sucker should be able to put out our fire because this liquid carbon dioxide
And it won't make a mess
I've also got some cardboard down on the table to help us clean up the mess a little bit easier
And I'm also using these black rubber gloves to help suppress any static electric shock because when dealing with black powder the last thing you
Want is to have it go off prematurely now? Here's the basic idea of our experiment today?
We're going to take these aerial shells that didn't fire yesterday
and we're gonna crack them open and salvage the black powder and the sparkly stars inside and
Transfer them all into one large container like this you probably recognize these things these are the shells that come inside
Kinder surprise eggs, and I brought these ones back with me after my last trip to Canada
So first things first, let's go ahead and crack these things open and see just how much powder we're actually working with
All right guys cracked open five aerial shells and that's what we've got some good fine black powder
Some of these little round balls there are stars
Those are the things that make it crackle and pop when it explodes
And we've got a couple of Kinder Surprise
Egg containers that we can use we could go with a small one and fill it completely full or it can fill at the bottom
Section of the bigger one and in this case I think bigger is gonna be better
So let's just go ahead and do it even though it won't be completely full
Okay, so guys quick update. I've gone ahead, and I've made the transfer
This is our five Ariel shells transfer it into the big Kinder Surprise egg
But unless it really doesn't take up much of the volume at all
We've only got about three-quarters of an inch of a layer on the bottom there just for good measure
I'm gonna take all these extra pink fuses here that didn't get used I'm gonna throw those in as well
But now the question comes what do you think would work better one of these things filled up completely full of powder or one of?
These things that would just filled up three quarters of an inch now since we have it. I'm going bigger
I'm going to just put this top on drill a small hole on the top and stick a fuse down inside then we can take
This thing outside and light it
Beautiful so here. We are guys
We have our Kinder Surprise egg with a nice fuse coming to the top and inside it's packed with black powder and Ariel shale stars
for one final effect
I think will be fun to wrap this up in a little bit of
Aluminum foil that would just allow the reaction to build up a little more pressure before it explodes should make it that much more exciting
Success guys
we have done it we put on about three layers of aluminum foil the idea being it will hold things together a
Fraction of a second longer helped build a little more pressure, this is the moment of truth?
This is where we find out what our improvised celebratory firework. Looks like let's head outside
So here we are guys. We just stepped outside to test this thing out. It is broad daylight
I know this would work a lot better at night. We'd see a lot more effect. However
I don't really want to store this thing in my house for the rest of the day, so we're gonna set this thing off
We're gonna see how it reacts and we're gonna do it in slow-mo
I've been saying this a lot lately that this project is about to be lit
Wow
Dang that was awesome crackly ball explosion boom crackle spark fantastic. Let's go see the damage. Oh
Oh the kinder egg is actually on fire the plastic is burning if you look down inside there
You can see there's a hole right in the bottom
Where all that gunpowder was it's absolutely shredded the tinfoil here. This looks like layers of lettuce just peeled back
And you can see how soft
This plastic is right now
It's on fire. It's very hot it's gonna pull that out
Try not to let it stick to my fingers, but look at that that is going down in no time flat
That was a pretty cool show
Where did the other part go whoa that thing is completely melted now. It is just melted down to a little puddle of plastic
Which is really interesting it almost looks horrible like could you take a Kinder Surprise?
Egg plastic melt it down and repour it into something else
That might have to be we try it in a future video because that looks
Very interesting there's our this lid doesn't have a whole lot of damage
You can see where the fuse went in it kind of burned that hole and made a little bit bigger
But other than that it just popped right off the top. It's really intact. It's just a little bit warm
It's a little bit flimsy not quite as hard as it typically is when it's cool
So you can definitely see it was weakest at the top the top blew off. That's burning my fingers oh
Let's go ahead and fold that in on itself to put out the flames
Now we can cool this thing down and dispose of our garbage
If you look down the road where this thing was you can see the different spots. Where all the sparkle balls went off
They actually left little scratch marks on the asphalt
Very typical of what you'd find from a normal fireworks show as well
The interesting thing is some of them leave a gray ash and some of them are a little bit darker
Not sure what the difference is, but that's going to come off with one rain falls disappear completely
It's slo-mo time. Let's see we got so here's what's interesting the top of the cap goes flying off
We got a big fireball that stretches out in both directions
You can see little tiny sparks flying off to the upper right corner
and
Then it turns into this giant mushroom cloud that just starts building out white smoke if you look down at the bottom
Now you can see flames shooting up and all these little tiny crackly balls
Just start sparking, which makes it look very very majestic that right there looks absolutely fantastic. It's great. I don't know how you describe
It's very magical
Flashes of light all over the place, and if you look down at the bottom
Those flashes are going crazy sparks everywhere
And of course at the end here all we're left with is a giant white cloud hovering at the top of the frame
So that was pretty cool all right guys
I'm calling that a success and here's why
We used kinder surprise eggs as the containers and filled it up from all the powder from our aerial shells that didn't ignite
We stuck a hole in the top insert a fuse and wrap the whole thing in aluminum foil to get a little bit more durability
Then we lit it off in the middle of the street in controlled
Circumstances and even though we test it out here in broad daylight the results were still fantastic
We saw explosions fireballs mushroom clouds
We saw sparks flying in every direction and pops and crackles going off which were very very satisfying
And a big shout out to Andrea flowers for suggesting homemade fireworks for the 4th of July Andrea go check your youtube inbox
I'm sending in 25 bucks now of course I do have to step in here and say that fireworks manufacturers
Do not want you modifying their product any modifications that you make to fireworks can be very dangerous
They go against manufacturer recommendations, and you can cause serious injury and/or death to you or anyone around you so stay safe
Let me take these risks for you, and I'll see you in the next video. Talk to you then
Where's the blowtorch when you need it
You